there are few places of peace in Hong
Kong right now but this is one of them a
temple
amid the tumult a Buddhist shrine that
is all about tranquility and harmony
qualities of late in short supply here
[Applause]
protest is what this place is about now
and protests that once had a target an
unpopular extradition bill is now
dangerously for China about democracy
human rights and fear for the future
what are you protesting about is because
the mace become more to tourism so
that's why we are coming out to fight
against this system is about democracy
democracy but this is not promised in
the agreement with China is it it should
be it should be doesn't mean oh we may
have a cup seam across Iran China but we
see neither fight because in Hong Kong
it's not telling you I think no one no
one will know I love you you know how
the way we will win or housing anything
maybe we'll lose maybe we will win but
we have to fight until we know the
answer but of course Hong Kong is also
about making money and in ko Shing
Street
Chinese medicine is traditionally big
business a kilogram of fish stomach is
about $7,000 u.s.
but the violence is killing the trade
here and dividing the generations it's
something that has to happen you know in
order for change so you know some people
don't agree with the violence but I
think that this is a way for the people
to express how they feel about the
situation which is which in my opinion
fu Lai
very hopeless Stephanie chan supports
the protests but as we speak her mother
sits under a picture of the Chinese
President Xi Jingping and watches Carrie
Lam addressing the people of Hong Kong
she thinks the violence threatens her
business everyone is worried about you
know the business and also other
violence whether it's going to affect
them personally you know I think that
you know Hong Kong's definitely belong
to China and also that you know we
should follow everything that you're not
imposing on us this family say their
business has been quiet for months and
blame the government as well as the
protesters this shop owner fears the
violence could severely damage hong kong
in the long run he says we will all
suffer because people who do business
will leave
traditions die hard here but the
cohesion of this former colony returned
to Communist China is under strain like
seldom before